one word that kept coming up over and
over again was the word disaster hi I'm
Zach why smaller with reason TV were
here with Emily Ekins director of
polling for the reason foundation she's
here to talk about the latest
reason-rupe poll Emily thank you very
much for being here thanks for having me
the December reason-rupe poll asks a lot
of interesting questions about the
health care debate and how it's been
playing out we all know about the
website woes and the if you like your
plan you can keep it kind of fib have
all these missteps affected public
perception of the federal health care
law it's not going well for President
Obama and his administration this is
their signature law and right now a
majority of Americans oppose the law not
only that a majority of Americans say
they favor the health care system that
was in place prior to the passage of the
law only a third say they like the
health care system better now that the
law has been passed so this demonstrates
that people do not see this as progress
or a step forward the way it was
intended to be when the Obama
administration has been challenged on
the whole if you like your plan you can
keep it they've said well a lot of these
plans that are getting canceled they
were just subpar plans they don't give
you the kind of coverage you need but
you ask people what they thought about
these so-called subpar plans what is uh
what you find we found that a majority
of Americans oppose banning these
so-called subpar plans and even when we
tell people that these plans are not
only low-cost but limited coverage still
a majority of Americans oppose banning
these plans people think that if you
like your plan you should be able to
keep it even if the federal government
doesn't think it's good enough you ask
people an open-ended question which was
to describe the implementation of the
law in one word so little Free
Association what kind of words did
people use to describe it well as you
can imagine most of the words were
primarily negative but one word that
kept coming up over and over again was
the word disaster the other words that
we kept saying included the words messy
and unorganized one word that was
posited that kept coming up was the word
good but generally it was caveated with
good but needs improvement or good but
needs some work a key to getting the
health care law to work is getting the
young healthy people enrolled in more
comprehensive ie expensive plans to pay
for kind of the sicker older population
you ask people what they thought of that
aspect of the plan what do people think
about kind of hiking the prices for the
younger healthier people to pay for this
other population this is essentially a
form of redistribution but
redistribution from the young to the old
and less healthy and overwhelmingly
Americans oppose having younger people
pay more in their premiums to subsidize
the cost for others and this finding
held up even when we gave them a series
of groups that could be benefited people
don't feel that young people should be
responsible for paying more obviously
the health care rollout has not been
good for President Obama's approval
ratings but the poll dug a little bit
deeper and found some interesting
results in terms of how this has
affected the view of government's
ability to administer things generally
what did you find we found about half of
Americans say that the implementation of
the health care law has made them trust
government less overall a majority of
Americans say they disagree with
President Obama's view on the role of
government not only that a majority of
25 to 34 year olds a key constituency of
President Obama's election in 2008 and
2012 a majority of those say they
disagree with President Obama's view on
the size of government so as we wrap up
I just want to ask for a preview of what
else we can expect in the latest
reason-rupe poll so we asked some
interesting questions about what
Americans think about raising the
minimum wage and what we find might
surprise you we also asked some
questions about criminal justice such as
mandatory minimums local police
departments using drones and we also
have some questions about the nanny
state the full poll results are
available now at reason.com forward
slash pull Emily Ekins thank you very
much for talking to us
for having me reasontv and Zach
waistline
you